Life as we know it started about 8,000
years ago and all the 24 billion years
old nonsense is just a bunch of Lies
cooked up by atheists liberals and other
assorted
hippies
uh that's interesting I'm glad that
one's in there cuz I actually don't
know if you're one of these young
Earth I don't know if you're in the
kenam camp or not I I'm more I'm more of
a P kind of gu
true say yes I'm I'm going to say that
you are I have a tough answer on this of
course you do but to to get the point at
least I'm going to say no but here's my
view which really could fall into either
category I do not have any strong
theological not not a strong theological
need or anthropological or historical
need to say that the Earth is 8,000 let
me just clarify one thing I thought I
didn't think they had a theological
reason to to say that the Earth is 8,000
years old I figured it was contrarian
purely contrar I thought that's that's
what would lead you there no it I guess
this is my issue I like the contrarian
part is nice too the issue
is one the 24 billion years stuff they
change that number all the time and
they'll say the universe is actually
half as old as they said it was or twice
as old or whatever so that they don't
really know but I don't
need uh the first chapters of Genesis to
be read literally and in fact I think
it's a bit odd to read them literally
but if I am convinced that the
description of the evolution of mankind
as given in the Book of Genesis right is
more
accurate than whatever Goble de so do
you think the Earth you don't need the
Earth to be very young but do you think
that it is that was the question I don't
think the Earth is very
young
if if
mankind I don't know how old mankind is
I'm not convinced by any of the numbers
that are thrown around and I what I am
convinced of is
that the view of human history as being
six or 10,000 years is a a
more uh insightful view than whatever
it's like 200,000 years and we used to
be like cavemen beating each other on
the heads or whatever so I but I so you
don't think
that that humanity is 10,000 years old
but you think that view is more
insightful no I'm saying that it is
10,000 years old is more insightful than
it but you don't think but you don't
think that it is or you
do to quotee CS Lewis no don't quote it
what quote yourself to quote Michael NES
to quote Michael NS to quote Michael
nles one time I read CS Lewis and what
he told me no I'm quoting me the Earth
is blank years old the earth oh I don't
know the Earth can be a bazillion years
old I don't care about the human species
is blank years old the human species
fill in the blank for all intents and
purposes no no I just say yes mean for
all intents and purposes well because
it's if some kind of evolution took
place whether that is um punctuated
equilibrium whether that is a kind of
minor type of evolution if some kind of
evolution if there was some breeding
between a group that we now
call well but the reason what matters is
this to to quote CS leis if there was
some kind of aplike human-like creature
and Life as we know it that's not even
human life life as we meaning like
mitochondrial you know existence like
everything around
you well everything around me is rather
young if you're saying like rocks and
stuff very young I mean the ground yeah
the ground it's old you don't have to
dig that right yeah the ground is old
but but Life as we know it meaning human
beings
uh how old do you think the human
species
is not counting like you know caveman or
Nephilim or anything just
human I
think anything we would describe as
human roughly 10,000 years old so you
think so yes is the answer no I would
say we got we went all around this
circle the purposes of my point no
because listen I I I don't deny it took
you 24 billion years to answer the
question we got back to there's there's
something like there's probably
something like a neanderthal in fact if
you look at the the mixtures of of uh
DNA subsaharan Africans don't have any
Neanderthal in them people who come not
from subsaharan Africa do have
Neanderthal there are different
breakdowns in like Aboriginal
Australians and all this kind of stuff
so like there were weird like vaguely
gorilla-like creatures who were
bordering on uh humans I think
neanderthals some have said buried their
dead what what does that mean I don't
know what any of that means I don't know
what all of this is about but if you're
asking me about something that we would
call I'm not asking you anything I'm
asking you about the card you ask
yourself look the card is very ambiguous
it's it's it's not ambiguous at all
really Life as we know it what is like
Life as we know it or life what are you
are you a li now you don't know what
life is no I'm saying are we talking
about a procaryotic cell or are we
talking about a UK carotic cell are we
talking about light the ex talking about
a virus that's not even life then
whatever you consider life to be well
we're getting real hippie man whatever
it's like man your life is you know okay
but so your answer is yes as my answer
judges in that in my beautifully
articulate description of of reconciling
the literal and the figurative where do
you rule is my did I say no or
yes I said no that's because Davies is
like a younger guy but Davies said that
because he thinks the Earth is like
three days old he goes even further you
know he doesn't he doesn't believe in
the 1950s
uh as far as the so so uh as far as the
Earth itself or really the universe to
me yeah I'm the last guy to say trust
the science because we know where that
leads this is all fake right however
um there there are some inescapable
physical realities so for example
there's like the the distant what the
young Earth Creations would call the the
distant Starlight problem that's a
problem to me it's not a problem but but
when you're looking up at the sky and
you can see a star yeah yeah that's a
that's a million light years away that
means that like that's proof right there
that the Earth has been around or rather
the universe has been around for at
least a million years this this is not a
problem for Catholics in in part because
the theorizer of the Big Bang was a not
only a Catholic but a Catholic priest
father George lra so that doesn't bother
me whatsoever um though they do kind of
change the numbers on how old things are
and you know they're kind of interesting
it's not going to be exact but I think
we know the universe is very very old
but I guess where it where the rubber
really meets the road for me is not it's
not even the age of the human race which
it can be whatever do we descend from
common ancestors Adam and Eve that's
where the rubber meets the road for me
where I I think yes well right but I
think you also touched on it that as
Catholics the great thing is that none
of this is like a problem monogenism is
though we Pi the 12 said that we have to
believe in a common ancestor yeah so are
you
you're not okay I don't know if you if
you became a Protestant on this episode
that would be big ratings well but
Protestants but but young Earth
creationist is is most thank you for
purchasing this game at dailywire.com
shop and for tuning in we'll see you
next
[Music]
time